just did something about climate change  for the first time in decades that's why  we've got to win this as that hurricane  Bears down on Florida we got a win in  the midterms we understand that really  distasteful stuff by the way people's  not only property but lives are  seriously in danger in Florida now  they're saying well if you want to avoid  hurricanes you've got to vote for  Democrats there is one man in the  history of the world who can command the  weather and the weather listens and it  ain't Joe Biden it's not even Barack  Obama even though Obama said that when  he was elected the Seas would stop  Rising the planet would heal but no it's  not Obama one guy walked around the  earth about 2 000 years ago the rest of  them are just pretending